c'est cet après midi à 15 heures 25 que
sera lancé depuis cap kennedy la sonde
voyageurs 1
cette bouteille dans l'espace en portera
le message des hommes pour une
éventuelle civilisations extraterrestres
c'est la troisième fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité qu'un engin construit par
la main de l'homme va quitter notre
système solaire pour aller vers les
étoiles de notre galaxie
mais c'est la première fois que le
président des états unis le secrétaire
général de l'onu monsieur kurt weill
times et 14 chefs de délégation à l'onu
ont enregistré chacun dans leur langue
nationale un message pour l'éventuel
civilisations extraterrestres qui
captera voyageurs dans quelques dizaines
ou dans quelques centaines de milliers
d'années quand voyageur aura quitté
notre système solaire dans 10 ans alors
les distances deviendront-elles que nous
ne pourrons plus garder le contact radio
électrique avec cette sonde alimenté à
l'énergie atomique mais d'ici là et
pendant dix ans voyageur un qui sera
lancé cet après-midi de cap kennedy et
voyageurs 2 qui sera lancé le 1er
septembre environ vers la terre quantité
de renseignements sur les planètes du
système solaire les plus éloignés de
nous et on peut dire michel chevalet que
ces deux sondes seront de véritables
machines à remonter le temps depuis
trois siècles des générations
d'astronomes suze les yeux et scruter
l'univers depuis trois siècles ils
empilent des verts de beezik dans de
longs tubes halle pour vaincre leur
myopie et ils allèrent même jusqu'à
concevoir des installations gigantesques
sommes ce télescope géant du mont
palomar avec son miroir de 5 mètres de
diamètre et paradoxalement plus on
regarde de loin plus on aperçoit des
étoiles jaunes le bout de l'espace ces
lots de l'humanité il y a dix milliards
d'années
l'astronomie est une machine à remonter
le temps
alors pour vaincre sa myopie l'homme
conçu des robots pour aller voir à sa
place et ce fut la révélation en moins
de dix ans on appris par exemple que la
lune ressembler à une terre figé il y à
3 5 milliards d'années que mars offrait
un spectacle est un homme en variés que
c'était le triomphe de la géologie avec
par exemple ce gigantesque canyon de
4000 km de long son sol était bel et
bien rouge
et surtout sa composition ressemblait
étrangement à celui de la terre mars
serait la soeur de notre planète en
somme la découverte de notre système
solaire commence aujourd'hui
ainsi voyageurs après avoir frôlé
jupiter saturne va se diriger en
direction d'uranus et la sonde sera
alors à une distance de 2,7 milliards de
kilomètres de nous
la sonde ne l'atteindra que dans dix ans
en mars 86 mais avancions 2,7 milliards
de kilomètres ce n'est que la moitié de
notre système solaire qui fait 6
milliards de kilomètres de diamètre en
somme avec cette mission voyageurs on
découvre en quelque sorte l'immensité de
l'univers par exemple voyageurs va
circuler à 54 mille kilomètres à l'heure
et bien si voyageurs à l'est vers notre
soleil le plus proche
proxima du centaure 4,2 milliards de 4,2
à des lumières je me trompe dans les
milliards
c'est à dire 90 mille milliards de
kilomètres et bien j'ai calculé ce matin
qu'il faudrait à la sonde deux cent
mille ans pour toucher le soleil le plus
voisin de nous comme quoi vous voyez que
l'homme jean claude bourret en quelque
sorte est prisonnier de son berceau
originel je crois qu'il n'en sortira
jamais il se contentera d'en faire le
tour
alors là nous ne sommes pas tout à fait
d'accord mais c'est un autre débat à une
autre question
la nasa a révélé qu'elle avait
sélectionné 47 scientifiques américains
et 12 britannique pour participer aux
expériences du second vol du laboratoire
spatial européen en 1980 le premier vol
aura lieu dès 1981 le laboratoire
spatial sera conduit sur orbite par une
navette spatiale qui le ramènera à terre
sans doute à la fin de sa mission
le laboratoire spatial et construit par
l'agencé spatiale européenne